good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday i am
very excited to be sitting down with
an icon a legend she is the moment remy
bader welcome back to the morning toast
as an official co-host you've been
promoted i know i'm so i've been
promoted i'm very happy to be here and
it is true because last semester i was
like nervous never met you before right
the guy downstairs was like oh you're
her sister go up oh
what and i was like i said yeah yeah um
but yeah last time it was just like a
different vibe now
no now we're besties yeah now i know you
and i feel so excited that we got you
here because we've been trying to
schedule you and we got you here when we
did because you're coming back from
coachella yeah
and i feel like following you know all
the instagram stories of the weekend i
was really looking forward to your
content
because it was in my opinion the most
realistic view of of coachella we were
talking about right before we we started
airing right now that the plus-size
experience at coachella is extremely
different yeah than everyone else's
experience and not a lot of people talk
about that so i just first of all i
loved your content so much i thought you
looked great i loved the green dress the
boobs were looking stunning um but i
just want to hear how that was for you
your first coachella and i i think
you've officially said you'll never
return again i'll never return um i
think that
i really didn't plan to it's like
interesting because i didn't think going
into it oh it's going to be so much
harder as a plus-sized girl like i was
just like i am going to plan my outfits
a month in advance right which didn't
like fully happen but really was like i
was pretty set and then it just like
everything went wrong but like not
not even wrong like i keep trying to say
like i'm not blaming you coachella
whoever the head of coachella is i'm so
sorry
i'm not trying to say it's coachella's
fault like
a but a giant festival like that i've
been to festivals like mini festivals
like concerts something like that
there's too many issues for a guy like
me i agree the sweat the chiefing the
chub rubs oh my god
i can't there was just and poor nikki my
poor sister just not going through any
of that just like so scared of me
um so
i the over now it's funny yeah of course
because you're home and safe and i never
thought that the content would be what
it was that people cared that much and
thought it was that hilarious like it
was just like i really truly in the
moment was like i'm i always do that i'm
like i'm just gonna whip out the phone
of course but i was like almost having a
conversation with myself and i'm like
what the hell is this i literally kept
asking people like this is this can't be
vip right i think we are wrong and we're
in the ga section right how was that vip
and i know everyone's like no you
weren't in real vip because there's an
artist right area didn't make it there
um
it's fine it wasn't for me learned a
lesson and i do think i do think that
when you're
mostly the outfits thing too it's just
like people
now i'm like realizing it's lame like
i'm just like with the competition of
who looks cooler and then i'm i didn't
think in my mind i'd be in like articles
of like who wore better things and i
don't think i wore amazing outfits like
i really truly looked great i thought i
looked fine and cute but i wasn't
thinking in my mind like this is a
contest right no it's definitely a
contest just now who can look sillier
but you've been to coach outlaw yes and
what did you wear i'm so curious um i
actually when i went to coachella was
the height of my thinness so i actually
looked um
like i had a lot of options in terms of
what to wear and i think i looked great
i looked like very you know hippie
floral but it wasn't at the level
yeah definitely
i went 2018 and 2019 i believe and it
just wasn't
it wasn't what it is now everyone
walking around it was kind of like
euphoria inspired but also cowboy
inspired everyone just looked like a
little bit like clowns like they weren't
sure what the theme is i'm hearing it's
very different yeah it was just a lot
and when i went the two years it was
very festival floral kimono
um
braids in your hair but not like glitter
everywhere fringe cowboy boots it wasn't
like that it was much more
civilized i think also people didn't
know what to do this year because it's
been two years yeah and everyone's like
ah and everyone dresses every day like
euphoria like that's the new style so i
think people tried to like be euphoria
cowboys and it just looked a little
silly definitely and then you look at
the people like i don't know i just like
once i got there like i thought i had it
down
and then i started looking at like these
like big time influencers with like the
craziest outfits and i'm like i can't
even get there so why am i now thinking
about it
just maybe i'm not but i really am not
saying like don't do coachella if you're
into the music and stuff if this was
when it was like beyonce and ariana
grande or something like i would make
sure i had the time of my life right did
you see harry styles i left before you
did because and nothing against harry
love
to it was like they were gonna make us
wait two at not make us wait what am i
saying it was two hours right from the
act before that and me nikki looked at
each other and said we gotta go oh oh oh
oh oh we're gonna lose our minds
i think that your perspective on
coachella was really realistic i
remember when i got back the first time
i was like there is so much they don't
tell you about the walking the dust the
heat the chub rub like there's just so
much unknown so i actually have a rash
on my face if anyone was wondering oh
yeah so you came back with a rash i came
back from mexico with a rash recently
and it was really scary i thought it was
cellulitis on your face no on my arm
what happened um i don't know it just
like went away okay but it was like it
took like three weeks to go away yeah so
and you know what's also annoying just
thinking about um
[Music]
i really truly i think that
i'm allowed to have that experience like
whatever it's just like the peop like
this is what i won't take it's like the
people that are just like
you should be happy that you got to go
to this festival you should be like and
i totally understand that but i'm also
allowed to have your own a little mental
breakdown yeah it just was my own
experience no i feel like i've known you
for a good time and like you're really
grateful for a lot of these i'm grateful
you've been afforded this was the one
thing that i've ever that i've gone to
that i've been given or something from a
brand or whatever it is that i've like
complained about publicly and i'm like
why am i are you getting backlash for
that no because it wasn't it wasn't like
direct from the brand i didn't go with a
brand right i went on my own and then i
had jobs there
i would never
yeah if i went with like a full brand
that paid for oh i didn't know that i
didn't do that yeah okay and you also
since we've last seen you you've just
been doing a lot you are now a part of
victoria's secret yes victoria's secret
pink pink i'm so sorry i'm so sorry you
messed up um victoria's secret pink
you're a model
i always forget you're a model i'm a
modeler last time i was here i remember
i was like i need to like do more shoots
because i like do one and then i keep
using the same photos of course like
fake model no but now you're a real
model i saw the looks from your
victoria's secret pink shoot it was
so cute thank you how does it feel to be
a part of victoria's secret who has you
know
a lot of scrutiny i'm i'm always excited
to be a part of things that are changing
like
you know i so i announced it with coming
out with their first
swim of the size xxl like they took swim
away completely right and then they
announced it with an xxl and the whole
thing was that i'm gonna help them
extend their sizing and actually try on
the clothes before production and things
like that to give them my feedback which
i've already been doing which is great
great um
but you know that's in the in this world
i'm in where i i kind of come right in
the middle from the mid size to the plus
size it is difficult because i got a lot
of backlash of like that's not xxl's not
big enough right and that's why i want
to be a part of changing yeah obviously
and i know like we're
this might just make like sound
desperate i mean like the fact that
victoria's secret makes xxl like is
borderline unheard of
um so yes it's a small step but it's a
step it's a step and i'm doing and then
i announce also i'm doing revolve remix
revolve which is coming out in september
which i personally can't wait for yeah
um
and claudia got a little sneak peek i
did it's really cute there are some
things you'd never know and then there's
some things that you would but what i
like like i show up on revolve like a
lot and i obviously have to refine my
search by size like for large to extra
large and it goes from like 10 000 items
to like 200 and it's like a little um
discouraging
so the fact that you're doing and
now i actually just go and search camila
coelho because she goes up to xl and
double xl um
so the fact that you're doing a line now
goes up to three x right
it is going up to three x it's gonna be
extra extra small so x x small to three
x fabulous again
of course the goal is to extend that
further but like you gotta start
somewhere you got to start somewhere
that is what we decided on at first i'm
very excited about it i you know they
gave me the option do i want to just do
extra large to 3x no i feel that that's
not inclusive i actually had so many
people dm me saying thank you that now
they could wear it because they're an
extra extra small and right before that
i was one of those people who dm'd you
right yeah yeah yeah i was like finally
i've been searching for an extra extra
extra small and i've never been able to
find it and now remy saved the day yeah
so i did it for you and i
um
i'm excited about it that comes out in
september and
i know i know that like half of my
following is just like we'll do more and
i want to and that's the goal and now
i'm i'm i'm learning from the feedback
i'm getting but i'm doing the best that
i can i just want to say i feel like you
get a lot of backlash like every time
you do something and it's every time and
it feels really unwarranted because of
course should there be a line that goes
up to 30x yes but we're living in we
have to operate realistically and the
fact that you got a brand like revolve
who's been known for years to not be
size inclusive is now doing a lineup to
3x while it doesn't sound like a lot
it's actually huge yeah and i feel like
you get a lot of backlash every time you
announce something like you're not doing
enough and i just want to say like for
someone who shops quite a lot and like
i'm a person i can't give away my money
fast enough i just don't ever really
find things to wear i just want to say
like on behalf of me like i'm very
thankful for everything that you're
doing and i think a lot of the backlash
you get is like wholly unfair
uh i was just thinking about that this
morning i was really thinking i'm like
wheat i can't even make what you can't
farm you can't fart without being out
without being yelled out lately like
even the coachella stuff which i truly
thought was hilarious content was fire
and then people finding a reason for
that to be a problem it's like i've
gotta find a way to just ignore and i
and i know you deal with [ __ ] too but
it's interesting because i i was
thinking about you and i'm like but i
think in the beginning i don't remember
you getting like in the beginning you
didn't really i feel like no not really
but i was also irrelevant like you just
shot up so fast and it was like really
kind of unnatural how fast you yeah yeah
you got here and i just really hope you
don't let it bother you like i hope
you do
well that's because it's so fresh i'm
telling you you will get to a place
where you've been doing this long enough
like you literally will not give a [ __ ]
and you won't even feel the need to
respond to some of the moronic backlash
comes and goes and sometimes people have
a legitimate gripe and you should
respond to it but i think most of the
time it's just people projecting their
issues onto you and so i hope you can
get to a place where like it doesn't
affect your mental health i do too but
you're not there yet absolutely not
someone yeah like someone yesterday like
looked like you're drinking a lot of
milk and i'm like i love milk why am i
responsible what does that even mean you
look like you're drinking i don't know
i'm i just can't i just and truly like
some days i'm not kidding i always say
this i'm like some days i don't care i
literally laugh about it woke up this
morning angry like yeah it's just it's
just the way day-to-day but like it's it
is comical at the same time it's just
like why can't i
make a move without anything but like i
got i you know i just gotta that's cause
you're doing big things if you weren't
doing anything important like no one
would care enough to give you backlash
so in a way it's flattering if you look
at it through that lens but it's [ __ ]
annoying for sure i'm just gonna i'm
gonna practice some different things
yeah trying to not look and we'll see
how that turns out yeah
um i also wanted to say remy is going to
my comedy show may 5th at madison square
garden and it's so exciting if you want
to come too with tickets available at
girlsnowjob.com
um so
you're going to do the past five with me
um are you you used to work at bravo
right that is like my favorite factoid
about you you know i actually went into
my email and i searched remy bader
because we had worked together
previously no like we didn't but i was
trying like i remember like michelle who
worked there was like right i might have
worked in the people and i'm like can i
email like i'll do anything so i
literally was searching in my email
because we worked we still do work a lot
with bravo to bring guests on and that's
working with the pr department and here
first of all the first email we have
together is uh like a chain about daniel
eicholtz from southern charm
remember that other spin-off that got
canceled savannah
so we're emailing about that and then
the second one um you sent me a screener
for uh real housewives of new jersey i
probably did something wrong and sent
you the wrong screener like i was so bad
at my job oh you did and then you said
i'm looping in nbc screener support to
assist you logging in i definitely got
in trouble
that's so funny and then my emails
transfer to tmt xremyvader which is just
a nice little full circle moment and
then when i worked at title which is
funny i think you automatically said no
but i invited you guys to like um
our title event
and and jackie was gonna come
and i was like so excited about that too
and then she was like can't make it i
know we are queens of cancelling it
takes a lot for us to leave our house
uh i'm
i kind of want to be like that though
yeah well so you're like fresh on the
scene you get invited to a million
events i'm better now though like from
the beginning i say no way more it's
helped me a lot
but i i think even maybe a little more
would be helpful just like picking and
choosing you don't what that's like one
thing when you're new
to this it's like you go to you know
like
lauren wolfe i'm always like lauren i've
never seen someone go to more things oh
my god lauren's wolf's tick tock like
physically makes me tired
yeah how are you always doing stuff
always doing stuff this whole weekend do
you like going don't you lay in bed yeah
she doesn't um i i do think it helps
because she doesn't drink it's like yeah
camilla cuellar i was like you guys are
the same like they could go out all
night on the town right and have a great
time which is i'm jealous of that me too
i'm uncapable of having incapable of
having fun unless i'm drinking but um
anyways what were we talking about you
were talking about title going to events
yes yes yes so i'm i'm getting a little
better like picking and choosing
i i actually told my team i was like i
need a good two months of not traveling
i want to be in new york state meaning
like at home home or in the city and i
wanna i'm moving i'm moving next week
can't tell you where i'm very excited
but no i'm moving within new york city
i'm very excited we all know i've
complained about my apartment for a year
now um so we got a
two-bedroom yeah big things and i'm just
like i really need to like be here yeah
and just kind of chill a little bit it
can be a lot it can be overwhelming yeah
um well i'm so excited that you're here
to break down the fast five with me
and i think without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
starbucks the new starbucks by energy
drink has caffeine naturally found in
coffee fruit but it's energy that's good
so it's a beverage that's crafted from
caffeine naturally found in coffee as
well as the antioxidant vitamin c so it
includes comes in three delicious
flavors mango guava raspberry lime
pineapple passion fruit we have them all
in the studio you guys know i really
don't drink coffee but your girls
sometimes you need some energy and the
starbucks bia energy drink is delicious
i love the mango guava it's refreshing
fruit flavored boost of energy that
feels good in a way only starbucks can
deliver so the each of the 12 ounce cans
cans
have 90 calories and they can contain
160 milligrams of caffeine starbucks bia
energy drink is available online at
grocery stores convenience stores and
gas stations nationwide again that's
starbucks bia energy and today's episode
is brought to you by zip recruiter as
well according to the latest research 90
of employers plan to make enhancing the
employee experience a top priority in
2022 after all a happy workplace is key
to attracting and keeping great
employees and if you need to add more
employees to your team their zip
recruiter their matching technology
helps you find the right people for your
roles fast and right now you can try zip
recruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com
toast they use a powerful technology to
find and match the right candidates with
your job then it proactively presents
these candidates to you you can easily
review these recommended candidates and
invite your top choices to apply for
your job which of course does encourage
them to apply faster it's no wonder zip
recruiter is a number one rated hiring
site in the us based on g2 ratings zip
recruiters technology is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
on the first day
find the right employees for your
workplace with zip recruiter
try it for free at ziprecruiter.com
toast that's ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t super cruder the smartest way
to hire okay remy are you ready yes
first story of the day sophia richie is
engaged to elliot grange um the model is
engaged to her music executive boyfriend
she revealed on instagram with a post
that said forever isn't long enough um
the relationship news comes just a few
months after he revealed that the couple
was ready to take the next step in their
relationship so obviously that was true
they are engaged everyone's quaking
calling scott like you know good luck
chuck that he was like the best thing
that ever happened to her and then scott
posted on instagram a picture of him on
a boat and wrote i'm in the 305 just
call me goodluck chuck which if you
remember that movie with josh dumel
every girl that slept with josh jamelle
would get married the next day so he
like started [ __ ] all these girls and
they would just get married and he would
get invited to all these weddings so
were people commenting that scott was
this good luck chuck got on so he saw
he's i believe he saw um i wonder if he
still like has feelings for sophia
because he stated like a lot of young
girls and probably not i feel like
sophia was like the one who could have
made it all the way
i just think he was like very insane to
courtney at that time and just needed
someone else yeah i think he's oh i i
actually really i do agree with that
statement i also feel like um
if this becomes a trend like amelia is
like getting engaged i was just gonna
say i really feel bad i really do feel
bad for not
oh i don't i just feel like there's like
it's just like for anyone if like all
these people that you're with start
getting engaged or getting boyfriends or
whatever and then you're just like damn
i just feel like that's not what he even
wants i don't feel bad for him for a
multitude of reasons like he was so
atrocious to courtney and even though
like as a society i'm always seeing tick
tocks like we ship them like we love
them they were like extremely toxic and
he was very bad to her and he put up she
put up with a lot of his like bad
behavior no i'm happy that she found
someone that she's clearly so in love
with he looks so happy and then after
courtney started dating these teenagers
and like it's not even funny it's really
gross and inappropriate so i love scott
i do but like i'm not out here um
feeling bad for him
i didn't even know
that sofia was with
this guy like i'm so confused where i
was like clicked his name yesterday and
was like
but i was just like where did you come
from and how long have they been
together they've been together for a
decent amount of time and why i think
this relationship is going to be
successful is because elliot is what we
like to call here at the morning toast a
businessman beau which means he's like
in the industry but he's not famous he's
not with sophia for fame or like to get
to lionel he is successful on his own he
keeps his head down he does his business
and i think that that is a trend that we
should be seeing increasingly more in
young starlets businessmen bow
i love that you need a businessman both
i do i was just going to say that would
you ever date like another influencer or
celeb i don't even know many male
influencers that aren't gay like
what fibula like i don't really know and
i'm not dating him
but i should say love fibula love him i
think the funniest thing about your
career on the internet is people are
always telling you to get a podcast and
no one knows that you actually had a
podcast
with fibula right yes and i tag him in
everything that every time someone
people are like you should get a podcast
i'm like at fibula no one knows no one
knew crazy
was that podcast with um i heart got it
and you you just didn't enjoy doing it
it wasn't that i just like know
i need to be putting my i need to be
passionate about what i'm doing and like
to put my all into it yeah and i think
that it was a very structured thing
where it was like we needed to talk
about like the tick tock like um
new trends of the week and things like
that i didn't care that much about right
but then i wanted to like if
i think that me and people are just
super different but like i'm obsessed
with him like i love him but i think we
just knew something wasn't
right right
and i
i am so happy now because i genuinely
like
love him and lady efron brooke and they
have a podcast now that i literally sit
and listen to and i don't listen to a
lot of podcasts except the morning
of course
and call her daddy and i just literally
sat
i literally what i don't even know what
that meant like i sat
i
sometimes they say really freaky things
i feel like your brain works in a
similar way that mine does where like
you're on a train like a thought train
and if you veer if you veer from the
train you can't get back on no i can't
and then i'm happy even in interviews or
certain things i'm like i'm so sorry can
you tell me what we were talking about
what the question was right anyways i i
think they're hilarious and i i'm like
it's actually one of my favorite
decisions i think not because not
continuing because i just knew that it
wasn't right and now theirs is thriving
and doing really well and i'm like i
knew it i felt it in my soul and it
doesn't mean i'd never do a podcast
again in life but probably would do it
on my own just because i think also like
we have different senses of humor and i
think with anyone it's like it's really
hard like i probably wouldn't do a
podcast with like my sister like i think
that
no even though we definitely have the
same sense of humor but i just think
that it's like so hard to find something
that like like clearly it's worked for
you and that's why it's continuing yeah
it's it's very hard to just make it work
no and then if you do it with a friend
like you never know what could happen
call her daddy no yeah like that i mean
i feel like that happens more than we
think in me it happens a lot yeah so you
end up just hating the person you work
with yeah which is not good so i i think
that if i ever did it it's like emma
chamberlain's style where she like
literally talks to herself yeah which is
really hard
but i could talk for a long time i was
going to say you talk to yourself in
your apartment all day long yeah
um
okay well happy for sophia richie
wishing her the best her ring is [ __ ]
huge and gorgeous [ __ ] i didn't look big
diamond thin gold band yes she posted um
on instagram and everyone of course was
like zooming it in i don't have the
details can i see your ring yeah yeah i
don't think i've ever looked yeah oh
look at that sparkle thank you
um i don't know the details like carrot
wise
but it's [ __ ] big and i wonder yeah
here look zoom like huge
love love she's so elegant like she's
real socialite vibes i have a question
did you before you're like before you
even got engaged did you were you
thinking about every detail of your
wedding already um
no yeah like i think something's wrong
with my sister like she keeps talking
about like every day she's just like
she's running and i'm just stressed
because i don't know about this i go
wait you're not engaged
i think i don't think that that's out of
the ordinary i just personally like i
was more excited about the idea of like
having someone to hang out with
permanently versus like the party okay
you know wait did you move in after you
got married after after i got engaged
got it yeah so i was just like excited
about that and like being like the first
in my friends i'm like i'm so advanced i
was so excited for your wedding to like
be like but there wasn't even much to
watch right in the beginning it was like
it was like pretty private and then we
did
that sorry i'm just like i'm such a big
celebrity that like i just i need my
privacy sometimes you know i'm sure you
understand yeah um okay a little bit
more scott disick news because he's
hanging out with larissa pippen in miami
and like we're very confused because
larsa pippen's on the outs
with the kardashians and like we don't
know what it means
scott disick who of course remains close
to the kardashian jenners um may have
administered the coup
okay like page six coup de grace like
just speak english
um the former flippet like disc star was
seen chatting with larsa pippin for
three hours at a friend's birthday party
in miami on tuesday the daily mail
reported
and photos obtained
show larsa smiling lounging on a shades
with her body turned towards scott so
obviously this is weird because um
like the larson of it all yeah did you
watch your house was a miami no it's so
good is it good it's really good i
i think they're i just think it's an
attention thing or i think they maybe
just like ran into each other at a point
i think for him i think he's just lost
yeah but lars i don't know we haven't
heard from kim on the subject but lars
has said on real housewives of miami
that like they're not on bad terms
and like nothing big like happened to
end the friendship they just like
drifted apart which i don't think is
true like because it went from being
bestie bestie bestie to no contact yeah
that's that's not a thing so there's
something there
and i don't think scott like talking to
larsa means that like lars is back in
the fold because scott is like on the
fringe these days like that's what i'm
saying i don't even know what his real
besides the kids like what his real
relationship with the kardashians is i
think that it'll i think that it's
literally have you been watching the
kardashians yes
um i watched this morning and i was
crying i was gonna watch this morning
but i really can i say like i'm really i
love i'm loving the hulu show but i hate
the fact that it comes out thursdays aka
wednesday at 12 midnight because i
wanted to watch last night i go to bed
at 9 30 first of all and then i wake up
and all the articles are already
spoiling everything everyone's posting
on instagram and so it's like what i'm
going to watch it before i could watch
it before the toast i watched it at 6am
i want to enjoy it like i want to lay
down not when i'm doing my makeup so
that's the only fault i have with the
streaming of it all yeah but i love that
there's no commercials
amazing amazing obsessed um
no not again
no no you were saying
um like oh yes like i think that it's
exactly what it
showed in the show that
he'll always be a part of the family but
it has to be a little bit awkward right
now yeah and i don't know if there's
like a real concrete place for him i
don't but i don't think that there's
ever like bad blood like i think that
they'll always which they should like he
has no parents it's sad i know like i'm
like
clearly like feeling for scott and
you're like i don't care about like i
feel for scott too in terms of the
family stuff like i think that i would
love for him to like always be a part of
their family but also now you're like
rubbing off on me because i had a
thought that i can't remember either oh
after watching the first episode you
know what i one of my main takeaways was
like in would it be possible in any
world that chloe and scott get together
no i i know it definitely like they
looked cute and that scene and i
understand i just think that that just i
think she's looking for something else i
think that's like her brother i think it
would be weird
i think it would be weird too but like i
can see a word a world in which like
scott and chloe are end game i know that
sounds psychotic given the fact that he
has four kids with her sister but i
think it's a possibility i mean it's
very biblical like if you're right
something would you be here for it
i don't want i want i'll never say
anything against chloe so like whatever
she wants oh right i forgot like you
literally live up khloe kardashian's
butthole yes i just posted me this
morning i saw on my way here that she
posted you on your instagram
i love that for you i live permanently
up kim's so like we could see each other
yeah um tell me about meeting chloe you
met her at nobu malibu right for a good
american event yeah i feel like a loser
because i keep talking about it but like
kylie jenner watches the toast so if
there's i didn't i totally thought
yesterday right yeah it's totally fine
just trying to prove to you that i
watched i know you did
um
she was great yeah like i mean there's
nothing i really like i just feel like i
feel very
i will stand up to her till the day i
die yeah and i used to be like that
anyways and now it just solidified it
for me because
she's a normal person
she's wonderful she gave me great advice
i feel like i i felt like when i was
saying i was crying this morning
watching the show it's because like
i just understand like i just people are
you feel this connection yes and i just
think like some i just think it's so
unfair that like i'm like complaining
about the [ __ ] i get and like i can't
actually it's insane the amount i know
and they can't fight back like it's
millions of people no and when you think
about a lot of the backlash chloe gets i
think what people don't realize is like
she's been you know accused of over
editing her photos and using facetune
and it's like if you think back to the
years where she was heavier than all the
girls and the absolute exactly terror
people put her through that put her in
this place where she feels like she has
to edit her photos like she's a
byproduct of our culture and so like she
she's bigger than the other girls and
she gets mocked endlessly she loses
weight and she's being told she's too
thin now and she's setting a bad
standard of beauty like you could take a
day off from working out like the things
people say but you wanted her to work
out before right [ __ ] off it's just like
that it pisses me off because i'm just
like i think in a way in my mind i'm
like
it's relating to me because i'm like
i'm like do i lose weight if i want to
do i not am i going to lose followers
like can i can you really do what you
want to do at the end of the day when
you want to be able to like win over all
these people it's such a like battle
and it's a battle you'll never win yeah
do you think often about the fact like
if your weight were to change your
followers would like fluctuate i said
this to chloe and she was like great
then you lose those followers and you
gain new ones right like like you have
to do what she said you have to do
what's good for you at the end of the
day because
that's literally all you have like you
can't just like be like i'm not gonna do
what i will make me happy for all of you
right and like work is important and
followers are important i guess but like
at the end of the day like when you put
your head on your pillow like it's just
you
yes and and and when i do think about
that too because my parents have asked
me and stuff i'm like i will never be a
size 2. right i never was prior it's not
happening i don't even know i wouldn't
even why it's on the cards for me but i
also wouldn't want it to happen i liked
my body growing up always being curvier
now it's just that like at a different
point because i gained the weight and
i'm allowed to be uncomfortable
sometimes when it's still new for me
yeah so um
i think that's probably
in my opinion would be the hardest part
of your job is becoming the face of body
positivity when some days you're not
feeling but that's why i'm like stop
calling me body positive like nothing
against body positivity like a victoria
garrick who like truly believes that and
i'm like i love her because she got to a
point where she feels this way and
genuinely loves her body every day and
like probably not every day no one does
every day but like mostly and like
that's her brand yeah i don't i look at
that and i compare myself i'm like okay
that's not my brand so that's why don't
call me that i'm not trying to be
someone i'm not people are like i and i
see in the comments and the thing she's
trying what she's not body positive i
never said i was never never said those
words no i'm not body positive either
i'm positive that i hate my body but
that's him
i'm positive no like i'm just like i
think it's so normal and it's weird that
people don't get that it's like if i
gained 60 pounds and i'm living in a new
body give me some time of course it
takes adjusting and then and all this
happened while i'm on camera and while
i'm filming myself and then people can
go back and from just a year ago oh you
look different so when i repost those
people are like oh you lost weight it's
just like it's just it's a weird thing
and i have to figure it out so yeah but
you know what like you also
i feel like you share a lot of your life
but you don't really owe people an
explanation for how you choose to feel
about your body you don't owe people
like reasonings like you wake up and
choose to feel how you feel and that's
on you i definitely like the one thing
i've decided to stop talking about as
publicly
is the food thing until i figure it out
like i'm like people ask for
advice and all this stuff and i'm like i
don't have the advice i'm gonna just
stop talking about it yeah
um well i love that
make a safe space for yourself remy
thank you and we're going to keep going
with the past five which are brought to
you by best fiends inner peace is great
and all but you know what's better
making it to with level 1000 investments
and that's what true satisfaction feels
like once you download best fiends you
can play anywhere even without an
internet connection which is great if
you're stuck without wi-fi so of course
if you're on a plane i've been on a lot
of planes recently and having a game
that doesn't require internet connection
on my phone is fabulous for my 80d on
planes you can collect tons of fiends
that get powered up as you play more
levels every win brings new challenges
thousands of puzzles to play
um they also have new in-game events
that are added all the time so you can
keep up with that they have thousands of
levels there's always more to play so go
ahead and let enough is never enough be
your mantra download best fiends for
free from the app store or google play
plus earn more with five dollars worth
of in-game rewards when you reach level
five that's friends without the r best
fiends available in the app store or
google play it's
free to download super fun and you won't
be able to put it down
next up in our fast five stories is oh
okay some click bait from the new york
post jada pinkett smith addresses the
slap in red table talk return she says
deep healing
so that is not true because i was
looking for stories this morning and i
went to um look for
this article and i saw it and i was like
oh my god so before while i was getting
ready i was like let me watch the
episode of our table talk so i can tell
remy what happened and not only do they
not talk about it they go along with
their regular it's a first season first
episode of a new season they have a
guest i think it's janelle monae and
it's just a regular episode but they put
something up at the beginning of the
episode like the smith family has been
through a lot they're deep healing right
now when the time comes we'll take it to
the table
so they're not even
addressing it so this article is
clickbait but what they wrote was
considering all that has happened in the
last few weeks the smith family has been
focused on deep healing
some of the discoveries around our
healing will be shared at the table when
the time calls until then the table will
continue offering itself to powerful
inspiring and healing testimonies like
that of our incredibly impressive first
guest
then the episode cut to a pre-taped
segment with jada her daughter her mom
and then special guest janelle monae
which was all filmed before the oscars
and then they made no further reference
to will smith's assault on actor chris
rock which took place at the oscars on
march 27th now click bait aside you were
at the oscars yes
well i was just gonna say okay i'll
answer first i mean that's not a
question
no no
well you're at the oscars and tell me
about your experience with the slap
i
want to stop laughing at me
i walked out
and you were rude you responded and
you're like very angry with me or
something i was posting about the slap
and you were like oh my god i literally
walked out of the room the second before
the slap and i was like
beyond disappointed in you because like
you're supposed to be you are the
representative of the people for you're
representing us at the oscars like you
could have a slap i could have had a
whole story i never went on and on you
could have went up to the stage like you
could have gotten yourself involved it
really made it really was the biggest
regret of my lifetime like i just can't
believe like i was just like
okay
you're it was like a 12-hour day like i
got up to do hair and makeup at seven
you looked gorgeous by the way thank you
7 a.m and then
you go to like the uh even the after
party i think is it goes to like i would
say like 12. so it's just and it was
scorching hot and i was in a long sleeve
velvet dress with a with the gloves so
it's just a long day so once i felt like
an a-list star when i was on the carpet
and then for a few hours and then i was
in the nosebleeds right so after a while
i was just like i need a break and you
know
it's really better to watch on tv well i
was watching the screen right so i'm
like why am i not going to rest right um
so i like to see it as long as i could i
want to see billy eilish sing
and then i was like it's it's time for
me to go like i see it like two hours
yeah
i am walking i left whatever and like i
was left with like a few people like
ricky thompson like people were all like
yes we made the right decision whoo
and then i get back to my room and
everyone's like me was that real remy
was that real ball blonde i'm like i
have no idea what you're talking about
like i'm taking my boob tape off what
are you saying and i couldn't believe i
just couldn't believe i'm like this is
when i called my mom right away and i'm
like she goes i am happy you left the
room because it's horrible and
disgraceful and i'm like okay mom i want
to see the drama
no no she literally told me seven times
that she's happy i left i'm like what
are you talking about such a mom thing
to say i know but i asked people and
apparently it was just we i think my
sticky boobs are falling off i was gonna
ask what boob tape do you use
whatever that was never again i had
blisters really all over my shoulders i
i do have the skims one that i don't
think they sell anymore and i need to
try it i have it too it's pretty good
yeah and my drugs are enormous
so like i'm sure you have normal sized
breasts like they will work perfectly
okay yeah i don't usually i'm like a
huge sticky boob girl and nipple cover
girl so i don't usually use boob tape
but for that it was like another level
like i was just like do whatever you
need you looked amazing your dress was
christian siriano yes it was beautiful
how did that feel it was really crazy
like it was i really enjoyed
i was gonna say i enjoyed every moment
that's why i was looking at hate
comments in the corner
but i
know i really was like
why am i here but i'm grateful to be
here why am i here meaning like why did
they invite right right who were you
invited by tick tock or bike
did you get an invitation in the mail
like how does that work um no like my
team was like the academy that is so
crazy yeah um but there was like a few
of us like maybe like 12 to 15 or maybe
not even 15 tick tockers which was
interesting because it was tick talkers
we were there for instagram
no like it was like to post a real not a
tick tock oh interesting yeah um i guess
they were partnering with meta right
right um and
it was just like we literally we were on
the stage at vanessa hudson's stage was
there's like separate sages and she was
one of the interviewers so we were both
vanessa hudson
vanessa hudgins oh you said hudson no i
didn't she did the abc you said hudson
[ __ ] we haven't no i didn't have it on
[ __ ] tape roll the tape
you said it continue guys i didn't just
like i saw your interview with vanessa
hudson she looked great
i didn't have an interview with her yeah
you played a little game no that wasn't
her
wrong now who was it with what's her
name oh god i don't know but she's
gorgeous was it e
it was on abc okay
i i have to look but it wasn't vanessa
okay so
oh vanessa hudson vanessa so we were and
also like you knew who i meant but you
wanted to yeah of course
one thing about me it's like i am the
most annoying [ __ ] on the planet and i
will correct you even though don't know
exactly what you do yeah so i'm not
going to let things slide i'm just like
annoying like yeah it's jackie's least
favorite quality in me really she'll
like flip away she'd be like i'm so
happy today i'm like hello
would i do that too
of course it's so annoying um but it was
it was
they couldn't we were at the end of the
carpet so no celebrity
could go into the dolby without walking
past
and we they really let us we took our
shoes off we stood because it was just a
long day and we like literally stood
over them and just were like and it was
funny too because it was just like
not as much me but like for like let's
say like ricky like people knew some of
the tick tocks yeah that's crazy like i
love you the only person that did to me
was um venus williams but it was still
exciting
people like literally thought like we're
so confused like probably thought that i
was asking her for her photo i remember
everyone being like and she's like she's
my friend i was like
wait what other celebrities knew the
tick tockers
um from west side story rachel zegler
yeah she knew rick
ricky or chris and was like oh my god
like yeah oh i don't remember it there
was a there was a few people chris olsen
who got oh
are you team chris or team ian
i can't say i met them both that day i
know nothing about them but i'm not team
i literally never watch them and then
once they broke up it came up on my feed
more oh i had seen them like just being
like you know coupley and annoying i
never saw them and then i saw this news
article and they broke up i'm like what
i was so surprised and then i've watched
your content separately i think i'm more
of a chris girly no definitely he's
really funny you should have them on
here yeah for sure um
i think ian's also like 10 years older
i'm pretty sure i don't know that much
about them but i like hung out with
chris that day like i i feel like we
didn't know each other but like you like
probably saw each other we both
literally just were like
hi that's how we said hi like i feel
like we were just staring each other and
then i just thought he was hilarious
yeah um so love him
have you met any tick tockers who were
mean to you
and like first of all i would never say
that okay then forget about the i don't
care second of all really like mostly oh
like everyone i feel like i've said this
before
instagram is what you think instagram is
where maybe there's some influencers
that might not be as friendly i wouldn't
say mean but like they've been in the
space forever some of them feel they're
more elite than others type of thing
tick tock is really like so we all want
to know each other yeah like i literally
have a group chat of east some east
coast tick tockers i'm sorry you're not
in it and that is so disgusting
that is so you are not my friend i am a
tick talker i know that is so i just
added yeah everyone's like remy who's
this number on my editing audience he's
a huge tick tocker
um seriously remy but it's admin cute
because we all like if someone has an ad
it's like can you all comment on my
website
like i really genuinely though feel like
every most people like everyone most
that i've met from tick tock like really
wants to help each other out what is the
who is the person in that chat that has
the least amount of followers is it like
way more than me
yeah
i'll tell you who's in the chat okay
it's it's random it started because like
there was not east coast people talk me
audrey peters louis levante who now just
moved to l.a
the jar
um
um okay honestly i don't know whoever
yeah stay at home daughter
okay you know um and kate i thought it
would come from here i thought it was
going to be like
like you and like other like i mean i
just don't know those people so i don't
need to be in the chat i'm sorry i made
like such a big deal out of it but you
can tell them all to follow me
i thought it was going to be like
literally don't put me in the chat me
mariah carey like i thought that's what
it was like crazy
that sounds really nice i'm happy but um
i don't need to be in it um okay should
we move on to the next story
next up nick jonas and priyanka chopra
have revealed the name of their baby
they're being like so weird and
secretive about this child like one day
like hey we had a child and then like
never brought it up again and now
they're telling us the name of the baby
because of course tmz sleuthed it out
and found the birth certificate who was
born the rabie was born via surrogate uh
in january um
it the name is
malty marie chopra jonas so malty is of
sanskrit indian origin and it means a
fragrant flower or moonlight
um really pretty so it's they didn't
like they haven't even shared this with
us it's just like tmz i'm sorry i'm
dying because i made the face at first
like
and then you once
i was like when you were saying the name
and then i was like oh beautiful it is
beautiful i didn't know what it was i
just thought it was like another name
that for no reason right no but priyanka
is very proud of your heritage i love it
malty marie
chopra jonas that is um a lot of names i
wish i had like you know so many names
what's your middle name it's my mom's
maiden name geller but my friend alicia
growing up she had like she's moroccan
and she had um alicia rebecca masuda
mazal chitri
and it was like so cool like she had so
many names it did turn out to be an
issue because like her passport and her
social security card like never matched
up names and she like wasn't allowed to
leave the country but um
i think she got it figured out i just
always wish i had like a beautiful long
name oh you told me the other sister's
middle name and we all have the same one
wow yeah but i was also thinking this
morning while i was getting ready like
what is your full name remetria like
what is the full
remingtonian right what is it no um it's
actually funny because in la the remy's
there for some reason are remington yes
yes they are um and i thought like on my
birthright trip when i met my friend
remington like she asked me if that was
my name i was like
like thinking it was a joke
um but it's just remy just remy yeah i
love that um there was a northerner you
should consider
no okay there was a northern italian
restaurant called remy which is very sad
because it closed during cove and i
would like go there and be like this is
my restaurant
my parents named me after because they
just walked by and loved the spelling
and then we went for my birthday a few
different years and like took pictures
with the men yet i don't know why i'm
acting like i've never heard this story
before like you just did an instagram
story about it yeah i'm just like a
fraud and a liar and an actress and i'm
like oh that's so cute like i know
i know this story so multi marie welcome
to the world um priyank i'm totally
respect people's privacy especially when
it comes to children so i'm not going to
be like annoying i just think it's
interesting how like we haven't heard
anything about this child like they just
dropped the news one day that they had a
baby be a surrogate and then like we
never heard about it again i feel like a
lot of people do that you know who just
did that who jen
had a baby
for a surrogate yeah oh cute like just
was like here's the baby and then i was
like wait because i follow her love her
and i'm like we we i don't remember
seeing you pregnant right surrogate i
think that might be me that's how you're
gonna do it i just like can't deal okay
so i have this conversation with jackie
obviously a lot recently because she
just gave birth yeah and she said like
the whole time she was going through her
pregnancy and the labor she was thinking
to herself like claudia could never do
this i couldn't i'd complain every
second i wouldn't be like that beautiful
pregnant girl i'd be like i'm miserable
yeah i think i'm gonna have to have like
some sort of gestational carrier
surrogate because
i just don't think that that journey's
for me i really don't and my mom gets
really upset about it when you say that
cries all the time and i'm like it's
actually rude because there's other ways
people can have a baby it's true and i
was like what if i adopt i might want to
and i was like and that better be your
grandchild 100 so she's just like i
think she just like
old-fashioned wants to see the
experience i'm like i don't want that
experience what do your parents think
about all of that's happened to you in
the last couple years
um mom's cries every day like i'm not
kidding like really really just
emotional about it like in terms of
grateful or like sad yeah hap just like
can't believe it oh good so like just
doesn't understand like uh when i'm on
tv at the oscars
like every crying all the time and then
i'll be and then it's funny because my
dad was like there was just nothing at
first and i swear just like he just
didn't think it was real like i feel
like he was just like
cool like what are you doing i was like
i got 10k and he's like nice like when
are you getting a job
um
and i think for him it was once i
started making money from this because
he's such a business guy
that he was like okay
and then but he like always says to me
like just know that this could stop at
any day like they're very realistic with
me where i am too that's like really
good advice to have around you yeah so i
but it like honestly it's the past like
three months until like
he'll go to arkansas to his buyers and
they're like oh my god remy's your
daughter like now that he has people in
his life and he's acknowledging it
knowing who i am his boss things like
that it's so different like he's like
and now he's like being funny like he'll
just text when i was this week and like
he'll text me and just be like i'm sick
of this not famous [ __ ] when are you
putting me in your videos it's true now
he wants to be involved it's really
disrespectful of you yeah and my
family's funny yeah so i want to put
them in more things it's just like when
i come out with the camera they're like
you can't film me without telling me
like well that's how this is gonna be
yeah right right right um
but yeah they're happy um i have one
more story for you it's a little
streaming news and it's brought to you
by credit karma want a new credit card
but not sure how i work with credit
karma yes they're the best i'm always
checking my credit score want a new
credit card but not sure how to choose
you don't need to apply for the first
offer you see in the mail credit karma
can help you zero in on the right option
for you and apply with more confidence
and if you've ever been rejected for a
credit card which happens a lot to
everyone credit karma created karma
confidence which is technology that
helps their members apply with more
confidence so credit karma uses your
credit profile to show you offers from
credit cards that are tailored to your
financial institution credit karma
partners with a wide range of card
issuers so you can be sure that you are
exploring exploring all sorts of options
best of all credit karma uses your
credit data to show you your chances of
approval before you even apply which
helps you apply with more confidence
comparing credit cards on credit karma
is 100 free and it will not affect your
credit score
credit karma create your own karma ready
to find the card for you head to credit
karma and check out your personalized
mix of offers today go to
creditkarma.com or the credit karma app
to find the card for you again that's
creditkarma.com or the credit karma app
all right final story is a little
business news netflix's world has been
turned upside down as their stock
plunges 35
the company reported tuesday that it
lost subscribers for the first time in
more than a decade the news shocked wall
street and sent shares plummeting 35
wednesday morning wiping out 50 billion
dollars in market cap and this was after
the company's stock had already dropped
more than 40 percent year-to-date so
simply put netflix's terrible 22 has now
become disastrous and of course this is
all because they have decided to stop
letting people share accounts everyone
has to pay for their own account
and uh people aren't happy i think maybe
i think netflix probably thought
that they would lose subscribers but
like also gain new subscribers because
people who are sharing like i'll just
make my own account but i think a lot of
people were like whatever [ __ ] it i have
hula hbo max i can use my mom's account
don't because like netflix has like the
ultimatum and certain shows that you
can't watch and other things what are
you gonna do yeah like i know but wait
so can you log on your like let's say
your mom's account like i don't know how
it works anymore but i don't think it's
as easy as it like it once was we have a
family account
we have a family account too and we pay
more for the family account but we're
doing it the legal like legal way we're
not getting in trouble so i don't know
if our family accounts are going to be
i think it's over change you think um
[Music]
what happens now when something like
this happens i don't know like i think i
don't know this stuff i'm not like a
business galley but i do think like
of course netflix is going to be fine
and i think they'll continue to grow but
like i think they probably this affected
them more than they thought it would be
like they thought it would be like an
edit that they made to their platform of
course there's gonna be a little bit of
a dip but it's netflix they'll always
come back i don't think they thought it
was gonna be as big as this and like i
just really don't understand why
netflix is so dumb because they used to
be the only streaming service in the
game
so they could charge whatever they want
they can make up whatever rules but now
it's like you have to keep my attention
netflix because my ass is paying for hbo
max hulu amazon prime i have all of
these and honestly as much as i watch a
lot of stuff on netflix
in an alternate universe i could live
without it so it's not like everyone
needs netflix but could you live without
hulu
no because i need to be able to see all
these shows immediately yeah i know but
like most people aren't like that is
what i'm saying i know i'm psychotic i
love shows like same but like people can
live without netflix if they also have
cable or they have other things they're
paying for so like netflix is no longer
the only game in town and they're acting
like they are so like you know hulu is
helping us they're giving us kardashians
like ever all these platforms it's a no
one has monopolies they just need to
keep making originals right
like let's say everyone just watched the
ultimatum last week like they're just
gonna have to continue doing that yeah i
know but i don't know why they just like
aren't acting more competitive like
they're not i feel like we're fighting
no i know but i don't know why they're
just not acting more competitive like
doing more things to incentivize people
to stay on netflix you should like join
the team and like figure it out 100 and
give myself a comedy special yeah that's
what i would do first day working on
netflix definitely did you um
watch bircherton season two yes what'd
you think about it um wait i heard that
you didn't love it as much i didn't love
it as much as the first one like where
was the sex scenes
i kind of did there were not minus that
because i would have loved the sex
scenes
but i i think i watched the first one
because everyone made me and i think
that i just was more locked into the
second one and like into there i was
like you guys please hook up like the
whole time i was just laying there and
just wanted them to then it got a little
much it got frustrating then it was just
like all right
40 times like just figured out yeah um
and then once yeah and then once they
did it it was like
now what yeah i just and we never got
them even [ __ ]
one people at the end they weren't
nipple
yeah we got nothing um
but i was surprised that i was into it i
almost i started it and i was like i'm
not watching this i really don't give
things a shot yeah i mean like shows
like i need to be hooked right away and
then if enough people are like please
give it a shot which they did i said
okay and then i'll try and not be on my
phone in the beginning once i'm hooked
i'm in yeah
um any other shows you've been watching
lately um i've been like so bad weirdly
i've been like reading a lot this week i
just like i'm kind of over my tv like
right now but um of course i watched you
at summerhouse yes love what are your
thoughts like are you team sierra page
or danielle lindsay
i really like danielle in life but i'm i
feel like i'm
more page me too i never like say this
in real life you know like who i am very
like quiet about no it's like awkward
like having opinions on reality shows
when you're now running
yeah i've never um i i can easily say
like i've
i've met lindsay a few times and every
time she goes what's your name like who
are you every time oh that's enough um
so
i don't really care about that but like
danielle's super sweet to me but i am
like pretty close with paige and sierra
and like i'm more their spare yeah i'm
totally team sierra and paige i've never
met lindsey or danielle i actually like
lindsay um i danielle is my least
favorite character on the show um and i
think she's a hundred percent in love
with kyle and it's just like so weird
how she chases him out of like
everything never thought that way now
that i've showed it to you like just now
i'm gonna watch the show like why every
time kyle gets upset she's running after
him like he's [ __ ] engaged like let
someone else like one of the boys
it's so weird like i just and i think
danielle does a lot of like pot stirring
to keep herself because paige was on the
show recently i think it's for relevance
and she was saying like it's actually
really hard to get the cameras like to
acknowledge you we're such a big cast so
much stuff happens we're all living in
the same house so people have to work
paige was not saying in in a negative
way she was like i do it too like we
need to work extra hard to get to be a
part of the core plot yeah and i think
danielle does it in like a really
obvious way yeah and i think if it
weren't for like her for some reason
like being lindsay's mouthpiece she
really wouldn't be like a core member of
the show
so those are my thoughts on summer so of
course i'm watching summers but i've
been reading a lot do you read no and i
just keep buying books i told you that
you should get into it only because it's
like really good to take like some time
away from your phone i almost threw my
phone out the window yesterday no i know
and like for me i'm incapable of putting
my phone down but if i get really into a
book like i can't even look at my phone
i've never your brain in my life done
that it's good for your brain what kind
of books do you read
i other than that no girl with no
job.com but i bought that of course and
like i supported you but i haven't read
it i keep trying [ __ ] read it it's good
um i read a lot of different things i do
of course love celebrity memoirs but i
haven't been into that as much recently
i like like really light-hearted like
sometimes like a murder mystery right
now i'm reading like this dumb book
about it's called welcome to the
neighborhood it's just about like this
girl who moves to like a caddy suburban
neighborhood and all the pta moms are
like [ __ ] just like sometimes i'll
never read stuff like that but i love
like self-help books like those are the
ones i buy like how to chill the [ __ ]
out i've never read no like those are
all the books i haven't read some people
have said my book is could be considered
a self-help book so you should read it
i'm gonna read it also that like there's
this one like i forgot what the name is
it's orange book that i've had for a
very long time right now and it's like
i don't know like a lot of people have
it it's crying in age mart
no it's one of those like self-help
people or like
oh it's a self-help book i don't know
and um i didn't like think that like
i've like had it around so i brought it
on one of the revolve trips and nikki
started screaming you're so embarrassed
and i'm like we watch she's like throw
that [ __ ] book out
universe oh
and she was like you cannot like you've
been carrying this thing around for
three years i'm like no i haven't she's
like what page you're on i'm like 26 and
she's like no this is actually
ridiculous i never want to see it again
like i have like a problem like i can't
i'd love to get into it so like a year
and a half ago i would never read jackie
would sit here and tell me about the
book she was reading and i'm like you
are such a loser nerd want to be the
loser um and then on one vacation i was
like be on board because we were like in
the mountains and she was like just read
a [ __ ] book and i read seven books
that week it was amazing i was like and
you never did that prior i never i
hadn't read a book since high school
literally wow and then when i was
writing my own book i was like i can't
expect people to read my book when i
don't even read so then i became like
more of a reader and really like tried
to understand the viewer like the
perspective of a reader and now it's
just a great it's great things on
vacation if you travel it's great pass
the time but also at home sometimes it's
nice not to watch tv i think that when i
move into my new apartment i need to
change lots of things yeah i get stuck
in my head where like this is my life i
can never change my habits by the way
same oh you know what i never realized
that like i'm the most stubborn [ __ ]
alive like if i don't want to do
something i won't do it but now i'm not
realizing like i started reading like
that's why i'm saying that's like a very
amazing thing oh my god you understand
like i cannot i'm literally like you
like i do not change i'm like there's
been things about myself i've wanted to
change for years i don't change but i
just realized i did that's like a huge
freaking accomplishment i think you
understand because like i've wrote that
down like i want to read like and i go
never going to happen it's me and it's
the same way i like put this whole like
story around like remy's a mess i'm a
mess all the time this this and someone
the other day said to me i forgot who it
was and was like you should read this
book because it helped me
do that and she was like i put this
narrative around myself that i'll never
change and be able to do things but it's
literally something you're making up and
you're in control of yeah that's so true
i love that what was the book do you
remember i'm gonna get it but like i
almost was gonna get it and then i'm
like am i gonna buy another book i'm not
going to read girl get a kindle
oh mickey told me to do that we live in
new york we have space for physical
books i keep all my books here i don't
have space at home yeah i haven't read
out like a heart actually i read gary
jannetty's book because i got a physical
copy but i read on the kindle like i
have no idea who that is gary jannetty
brad gresky's husband
okay so he is brad grasski's husband but
like on his own he's like super
accomplished writer for
family guy for a million years um
and
he's gary genetic on instagram you don't
follow him no oh my god he's beyond
hysterical excuse me and he just wrote
his second book and they're so short
stories they're hilarious it's really
short actually would be a good place for
you to start just like funny things that
have happened to him is like i'm dying
that you're the biggest reader now
you're like oh you didn't hear that book
no i know i'm literally such a reader
and like i i'm so pretentious and like
the way i used to like hate jackie for
it you probably hate me now
yeah like that's how i've been with my
sister like growing up seriously on
vacation she would read every book and i
would be like listening to my eyeball
nana right like let's go swimming yeah i
would make friends on vacation all the
time did you ever do that never a day in
my life really like any sisters no like
we were
i got it you were nicki was too mean if
he didn't speak so like she would be
there like she was like sitting there
angry she was younger two years older
okay and she wanted nothing to do with
me so i would literally walk to people
in the pool do you want to be friends
and i would and i would stay friends
with them for like years oh that's sweet
yeah i love people you're such a people
person
i love having you on the toes thank you
so much for being here i really
appreciate it having me everyone follow
remy on instagram at remy jay bader or
just remy vader we left my email i'm
freaking out oh okay so
remy bader e m i b a d e r i don't know
where i pulled that on instagram and
tech talk but like i might start a
youtube soon just letting you know you
should even though it's a lot of work
before you commit to it okay but like i
need to okay everyone's asking um remy
vader also follow me on tick tock girl
no job i'm gonna make i'm gonna make
remy make a tick tock with me right
after this oh we should so make sure to
go like that tick tock have an amazing
day thank you guys so much for listening
to the morning chelsea monday morning
show we're back tomorrow remote jackie
cannot make it in studio and we are
respecting mothers over here so we're
just doing a podcast with jackie
remotely thank you so much for listening
to the morning chess monday morning show
where we deliver the five stories you
need to know everybody friday on youtube
watching this on youtube please
subscribing this video thumbs up
roseville's pockets never [ __ ] gets
me found that spotify i just hit your
public radio i already have spots all
the places and podcasts find out more
just sleep if i starve you better
beautiful soundings
have an amazing day you guys will see
you tomorrow for
friday friday gotta get down on friday
that was good yeah bye
you